federal investigators are trying to
figure out who made a wave of bomb
threats across the United States and
parts of Canada it turned out to be an
elaborate extortion hoax the email
threats demanded $20,000 in payments in
Bitcoin targets included government
buildings schools businesses and news
organizations from San Francisco to New
York Jeff Pegues is outside of the FBI
headquarters in Washington Jeff good
morning good morning the FBI is
assisting local law enforcement in
responding to all of these threats
they've been received in nearly every US
state it is unclear at this time how
many threatening emails were sent but in
New York City alone 30 to 40 were sent
to various locations the reports of bomb
threats spread like wildfire across the
country this bomb with mass evacuations
from coast to coast in Des Moines Iowa
police scramble to answer a flurry of
calls in about 40 minutes we had four
businesses here in town get a hold of us
and say that they'd received bomb
threats in San Francisco calls came in
from close to 20 locations the types of
businesses affected by these bomb
threats range from offices financial
institutions as the calls came in
officers and good jeopardy
bomb sniffing dogs soon followed but in
every city in small town the end result
was the same we have not found any
explosive devices or found any of the
threats to be credible CBS News has
learned that in recent weeks federal law
enforcement officials sent a bulletin to
local police departments across the
country warning of digital ransom
threats after 15 states receive similar
messages between August and November of
this year the very basic consequences to
an attack or even a threat like this is
that a cost business it cost government
it cost taxpayers a lot of time and
money
CNET senior producer Dan Patterson says
cyber criminals may be testing new
methods to see how we respond inevitably
at some point we will have to contend
with a cyber attack that harms or
damages a city may end up resulting in
the loss of life
but right now the priority for the FBI
is stopping the spread of these
threatening emails one threatening email
that was sent to a Missouri middle
school was traced to an IP address in
Moscow typically in these cases the
suspects are pretty good at covering
their tracks and leading investigators
down dead ends
Gale very disturbing stuff this morning
thank you Jeff